[Musique]
également beaucoup nous ont dit ce n'est
les oreilles
deuxième génération et troisième
générations qui sont avec un design qui
à mi chemin entre les herbes folles ou
de deuxième génération est sortie hier
de secours pour autant ici on n'a pas de
réduction proactive voilà donc c'est
normal mais je suis aussi bien la
différence de tarif et on pourrait s'en
voir ce que cela soit des espaces pour
autant ce ne sont pas des infra il vient
de se poser comme l'airpod c'est-à-dire
et aime se poser sur vos oreilles comme
des repos d'une génération dont il vient
d'hériter pour regarder se poser
l'accent vaudrait aujourd'hui aux
râleurs des cils sont intéressants s'il
faut se positionner et là tout de suite
le son capté savoir si ce traitement
direct vers quoi de troisième génération
alors tout passe par le logiciel file
des bourses ne sont pas des micros donc
servir à tourner coach yves donc ne vous
posez pas de questions sur la qualité
pour être noir avec ici de sa génération
savoir eh bien si malgré tout avec le
vent et la vitesse on arrive à bien
entendre c'est surtout ce qui va bien
vous intéresser ici aujourd'hui voir si
la tenue est bonne voire si le confort
est bien qu'un seul tour facture par il
fait beau et chaud ses choix c'est beau
[Musique]
c'est sympa de retrouver paris avec des
mots comme ça alors là change is plus
maintenant là dessus j'ai directement
sur le micro de l'iphone première chose
que je veux vous dire sur mon retour
quel sens en baladant au nom du vélo se
trouve que il tient bien dans les
oreilles et pour voir qu'on n'est pas
son désir accompagneront vissé à
l'intérieur des oreilles en chou c'est
quand même assez rassurant plutôt pas
mal ça tient bien franchement solution
n'est pas et ça secoue tous les goûts
d'un participant à diverses interviews
donc ça c'est cool la tenue est bien le
confort est bien pour autant on entend
un peu ce qui passe autour de nous ça
vient petit peu nous boucher de
l'extérieur mais pas non plus énormément
donc tenue est bonne
le confort est agréable qu'on entend ce
qui se passe sont trop importantes ne
sont pas d un trail viennent peser sur
mon travail c'est cool et en plus de ça
ce qui est sympa du coup beaucoup de
choses simples aujourd'hui et bien c'est
qu'ils sont certifiés résistant à l'eau
et à la poussière certification ipx4
donc si je veux pas l'être comme ça dans
paris que je veux y aller on espère le
voir ça devrait aller et si je [ __ ]
comme un dingue échelle va transpirer
comme un fou ça devrait aller donc ça
aussi c'est court
[Musique]
quel bordel mythique offrit un chemin
dans les cartons on sera en studio tour
d'ici quelques temps il ya encore pas
mal de choses à mettre en place vous
avez un très joli nasa 80 terra de
stockage je pense que là il ya ce qu'il
faut pour arrêter les anciennes vidéos
et celles qui vont venir c'est ça qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est ça qui
nous attend ça c'est vachement
intéressant pourquoi parce que c'est
vrai qu'on dit toujours où apple une
forte des produits c'est cher et là
c'est vrai que ce truc là normalement on
arrive alors comme ça
les perdure ce truc là ça m'a bluffé
quand même vachement bluffer tout autant
que j'ai été bluffé avec les premières
poste quand je les ai découvert parce
que on se dit qu'avec des écouteurs
comme ça alors c'est pas des intra sur
des écouteurs rappelons le tarif jeu les
199 euros on se dit qu à 199 euros sans
réduction brute active faut quand même
avoir un peu de couilles pour y aller et
on se dit bon apple c'était un petit peu
compliqué parce que il ya aujourd'hui
plein de super écouteurs avec des
applications qu'on peut trouver sur un
os avec de la réduction de bruit actif
qui vont être un peu moins cher pourquoi
est ce que j'irai acheter un produit
apple a un petit peu moins de 200 euros
je vérifie le tarif favorise les
protocoles complètement mémorisées ça
paraît dingue et en fait c'est là où
c'est dingue c'est là où la magie opère
parce que au-delà d'avoir une expérience
100 % à optimiser bien évidemment c'est
du apple et apple fait du apple et
surtout le saut qui supplante beaucoup
de produits dans cette catégorie et sans
réduction brute active et ça marche ça
là j'ai vraiment bien et c'est là-dessus
qu'apple extrêmement fort parce que la
qualité elle est vraiment là et autant
jeter est plein de produits très cool
des produits en audio à 179 150 balles
il y en a plein j'en ai testé des tonnes
ils sont intéressants et ils sont bien
dans la réduction d'activité équaliseur
ne tue pas c'est bien ça marche c'est
équilibré mais là on est quand même au
dessus on est au dessus et ça marche
super bien les basses ça ronronne ça ou
ça grouille c'est vraiment vraiment bien
et c'est même assez bluffant par rapport
à la taille de ce petit truc là les
aigus sont précis les médiums sont pas
sains précise tout est prêt si tout
marche très bien dans la bande de
fréquences alors attention ici c'est
précis lorsque vous êtes jusqu'à un
volume aux trois quarts quand vous
commencez à monter au dessus des trois
quarts du volume de votre iphone par
exemple ici eh bien on va perdre des
basses on va être plus dans le médium ça
va être un peu moins précis le spectre
va être déséquilibré mais c'est normal
on est quand même sur des petits driver
là dedans doro n'a pas eu l'ondé la lune
mais malgré tout le son est vraiment
cool donc c'est vrai je voudrais
vraiment à venir les écouter à venir les
découvrir parce que apple a fait du très
bon travail là dedans donc l'expérience
audio elle est vraiment super et c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec rhinochill parce que
oui avoir de très jolis airpod c'est
bien mais vous pouvez en plus de venir
protéger votre étui avec des jolies
coque cinieri dauchy et léché rideau
shield et comme vous en avez plein ça
c'est une coque pour airpod propre parce
qu'elles sont en train de finaliser les
coques pour vos épaules de troisième
génération je monte donc sur la coque dr
paul trop regarder sympa ça vous venez
vous l'ouvrez et pierre pause protégé
pouvait bien l'attacher pour le mettre
un porte clés pour bien mettre à votre
pantalon vous faites comme vous voulez
et y en a plein sherine au chili vous
entrez dans l'univers de league of
legends de dragon ball z bref il y en a
des tonnes allez jeter un coup d'oeil
sur le site de rideau chine je vous mets
un lien en bas dans la description et
avec le code greu 21 vous avez 5 % de
remise sur tous vos achats chez
rhinochill pour mieux protéger votre
iphone votre ipod une protection d'écran
et en plus des câble tressé grand
sécurisé bref y en a pour tous vos
besoins le lien en bas et dans la
description et n'oubliez pas le code
grue 21 pour à marveaux 5 % de réduction
et ça c'est une très bonne chose et
bercy rideau shield avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo pour venir passer des coups
de fil vous avez entendu l'audio bon ça
marche il ya un petit micro ça
fonctionnera c'est pas un truc de dingue
première s'enregistrer mais ça fera
parfaitement la sphère en plus dans une
petit truc qui est assez malin c'est
qu'ils vous ont mis du tissu mesh en
tissu mesh sais quoi qui est bien c'est
un petit tissu qui est planqué lagarde
est juste là pas forcément évident de
s'en rendre compte qu'ils planquent est
ici là et en fait ce tissu mesh qu'est
ce qu'il vient faire eh bien il vient
fils créé le vent qui va arriver de
l'extérieur pour optimiser la qualité de
votre voix lors vos appels téléphoniques
et ça marche bien et c'est bien réussi
je vous passe l'idée de la puce h à
l'intérieur je vous passe tout ça il ya
un autre qui est assez intéressant c'est
au niveau de sa belle l'audio spatiale
alors qu'est ce que ça vient faire
l'audio spatiale bien vous venez
l'enclencher directement notamment ici
dans votre iphone et ce qui est super
intéressant avec cet audio spatiale est
bien c'est que lorsque vous écoutez du
son et vos écouteurs vous avez droit de
gaucher la stéréo leçon bien la leçon
vient de là alors grâce à la stéréo on
arrive à voir en dessous un petit peu
comme ça et l'audio spatiale ça ouvre
messaoud vraiment je trouve ça
intéressant à regarder un film on est
plus en immersion mais je trouve que
lorsqu'on écoute de la musique on est un
poil plus dans le médium et on va perdre
en précision je préfère ne pas activer
l'audio spatiale lorsque je vais venir
écouter de la musique même si c'est vrai
qu'il a un côté un peu bleus face à ça
ajoute de l'air il centre dans une plus
grande pièce mais plus sur le médium et
plus imprécis donc c'est pas trop trop
mon truc qui a aussi une autre techno
qui est pas mal qui s'appelle
l'égalisation adaptative alors on s'en
rend pas compte c'est complètement
transparent sata partie de la magie que
va nous offrir apple avec ce produit là
c'est à dire que ils vont venir capter
tous les sons extérieurs notre
environnement est adapté l'égalisation
c'est à dire les basses les médiums et
les aigus pour vous proposer toujours
une expérience optimisée c'est pas vous
qui avez la main un autre art une
application à moduler votre équaliseur
non c'est lui qui le fait de façon
intelligente et vous avez également de
l'audio spatiale avec les appels de
groupe alors moi j'ai pas pu tester j'ai
pas plein de potes qui sont sur facetime
mais c'est une technologie qu'apple vous
propose d'essayer l'attesté d'ailleurs
dit moi aux commentaires si vous avez
testé ce que vous en pensez mais moi
personnellement je n'ai pas fait ce que
ça vous fait c'est de pouvoir retrouver
la personne là où elle est par rapport à
sa position sur wolfenstein
petit gadget mais pourquoi pas après
avoir trouvé des commandes un petit peu
standard ici c'est à dire que je vient
appuyer une fois music player pause on
m'appelle je raccroche jorat puis je
décroche deux fois morceau suivant trois
fois morceau précédent je laisse un
appui long je peux appeler syrie et ce
qui va me manquer ici au niveau de
l'expérience ça serait de pouvoir
réassigner j'ai pas les plots sur la
droite je monte le volume d'appui au sol
à gauche je baisse le volume ça ne
m'aurait paru intéressant et s'il faut
pas le faire alors on fait partie un peu
de l'idée d'apple ici c'est à dire que
si vous avez des paloises vous le faites
avec votre mon troupeau est bon pourquoi
pas mais il faut avoir une apple watch
sinon il faut aller sur votre iphone bon
ou sur votre mac avoir ou sur votre ipad
mais ici on va jusqu'à 30 heures
d'écouté avec une seule charge alors
j'ai pas mis trente ans de suite et
écouter de la musique mais c'est
vraiment cela nous annoncé apple 6
heures directement écouteurs par
écouteurs et jusqu'à 30 heures avec
votre petit étui et 20 heures en appel
bon une fois de plus 20 heures en a pas
eu de suite je pense de faire mal à la
tête et vous pouvez leur charge et bien
évidemment ici en lightning en dessous
mais également en accès sans fil et avec
un chargeur compatible qu y est ils ont
lancé un nouveau truc qui est assez
marrant c'est à dire qu'en fait vous
avez vos capteur de présence la la
lorsque vous allez poser dans vos
oreilles qui vont venir acte iv
uniquement contre de la peau donc c'est
que ça vient reconnaître votre peau et
si vous le mettez sur un support inerte
par exemple une table où j'en sais rien
moi contre du bois et bien ça ne
marchera pas ça allait vite qu'ils
viennent se relancer lorsque vous les
mettez dans une poche ou en tout cas ce
que je vais vraiment aimé ici c'est déjà
un format qui est un peu plus petit par
rapport aux airpod qui fait penser aux
airpod pro sans être pour autant
derrière bolt pro je trouve vraiment
sympa ils tiennent très bien dans
l'oreille sont pas d un trail viennent
pas boucher le conduit auditif mais pour
autant ils viennent reposer il repose
très très bien et surtout ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la qualité audio je la
trouve extrêmement bluffante alors on
regarde positionner la gamme ici on est
à 199 euros si vous voulez acheter
l'airpod de deuxième génération vous les
trouverez à 149 euros il reste très bon
les airs pop ce pro sont à
279 euros on en a un petit peu plus avec
leurs poses trop et notamment la
réduction de l'actif qui va venir nous
intéresser ici et ensuite on n'arrive
carrément tout heureux que l'airpod max
sont annoncés sur le site d'apple à 629
euros et qu'on peut trouver un petit peu
moins cher ailleurs cette gamme de ipods
je trouve intéressante est ce que pour
autant aujourd'hui je voudrais acheter
dr paul de deuxième génération versus
l'airpod de troisième génération cas il
ya une vraie différence de prix un
tassement thierry si on a quand même 50
euros d'écart après à vous de voir ça
dépend de vous et de vos finances mais
par contre si vous voulez acheter dr
poste de troisième génération et que
bien évidemment que vous êtes chez apple
vous avez des produits apple si vous
êtes chez android ça pourra marcher mais
il faut l'acheter si vous êtes chez
apple c'est vraiment là où c'est
extrêmement intéressant et bien c'est un
petit produit qui marche vachement bien
et je vous le dis une fois de plus on
pourrait se poser la question de la
concurrence vous avez des produits de la
réduction de bruit active à accoter
enfin ouais ok mais ça c'est totalement
optimisé pour apple et au delà de ça la
qualité sonore elle est tellement la
corogne pour ça on oublie la réduction
brute actif un peu moins de 100 balles
mais moi je trouve bien vraiment à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire comment vous les trouvez
cr potes de troisième génération moi je
suis bluffé j'aime beaucoup franchement
beaucoup aller des bisous de l'amour
d'être évident
[Musique]